I thought I would scare you really are we
recording yes
hey guys welcome to the Evan and Katelyn
podcast where I definitely can't
surprise my wife alright guys so in
today's episode we will be talking about
how we started making products and then
why we stopped
then we're gonna play two truths and a
lie and that's it
yeah I like pitching and selling like
what we're doing in this episode or like
I mean we could say like we're gonna go
into the hold card hold cards with the
cold hard truth about why we stopped
making products well I hear about the
cold hard truth even the heart that hold
card the hold card truth alright moving
on I think that we've told the story
maybe somewhere I just can't remember
where but we didn't bits and pieces and
bits and pieces but like our whole
product making journey hasn't ever been
in one concise place
and it all started when I quit my job
mhm
I just gotten too much I knew I wanted
to do something else this is the first
job not the first job but in earlier job
not the job you most recently quit - the
whole like job back and forth thing
that's a whole there's a whole another
story I mean like I I quit I went
part-time I went full-time I want a
part-time and I quit again yeah
basically but the first time we quit but
the first time I quit it was because I
knew I wanted to do something else and I
just needed time to figure it out have
enough time to think there's no mental
capacity to figure it out but then I
think once you did quit I think your
first instinct was like making something
yeah and that's because that's what I
had been doing for my entire
professional career I had been designing
manufacturing you know doing prototypes
and then ramping that up to full-scale
production at a very rapid pace so I
knew I could design thing
I've been thinking of ideas for things
in my head for the longest time and and
and I thought that that was the path I
wanted to go in a way that's what I
thought I wanted to do since I was a
young kid invent things make them all of
that stuff but I mean this is kind of
getting into another thing but through
what we're doing now I found out that
the main thing I want to do is just
making things the first time but we'll
get into that later so so some of the
first stuff that you made and this is
before I was really involved in making
any types of products you were you made
some like camera accessories camera
accessories I was thinking of some
household products one I still want to
do so long ago I'm still in our list oh
yeah you one you had was like the self
balancing yeah slider
oh yeah the monopod why am i blanking on
the names like this fancy like there's
like an omnidirectional ball in it and
then weights and then like it could be
like a like monopod or a like stabilized
stabilizing and like I just love
multifunction things I like things that
are small that can do a whole bunch of
things yeah I just like that's if I were
to have an obsession for like a type of
product like what's your favorite type
of product multifunctional small things
they do a lot of things but that's the
direction I was going in and we got the
3d printer it's not like prototyping and
then I also opened that printer up for
like helping manufacture things for
other people and I was doing that yeah
3d hubs that were people can submit
designs that's no longer what they do
they yes i they don't do it for like
hobbyists anymore so many professional
people yeah the whole the whole 3d
printing industry is still so much in
flux it's crazy
well that was a hard to make any like
reasonable money on because it was and
also like the the most people aren't
aware of the limitations of 3d printing
and the expectations are that was just
like magic and reality and expectations
but at least at the time when you were
doing and it was still yeah pretty new
and kind of like mysterious yeah but
then for Christmas I made the 3d printed
deer for you and then it's just to
describe it people haven't seen it it's
like he he made this this thing for me
and I'm not sure what give you the idea
to make an initially or why I forget we
were into like geometric deer heads oh
really
yeah so I think I was just messing
around with 3d modeling programs yeah
and one of the programs is a mesh 3d
like program because you knew that
parametric mathematical based modeling
or you can have polygonal modeling with
like meshes and triangles and and stuff
like that and I wanted to understand
both and I had some experience with the
mesh based thing when I was doing
animations for work and I just wanted to
keep up my skill so I got into modeling
animals you are a very important part of
my choices just so you can picture it
it's it's a 3d printed kind of geometric
faceted deer head that he painted gold
yeah yeah a deer like a deer head yeah
not really the best kind of yeah yeah
yeah was like cool over exaggerated
antlers and stuff yeah and and I don't
know what I think I was just doing
research one day on like where we could
sell products at a smaller scale yeah
locally smaller scale because another
thing that I thought about selling are
the marquee letters and that's actually
what led us down the path of selling
products because we're like let's let's
start selling something now what's
something that we know people want
people want to buy the marquee letters
yeah we got a ton of requests for them
exactly like back when in the blogging
days where you'd get requests all the
time and even still sometimes for like
friends and family can we like can
can we pay you to make us some and yeah
so we're like okay well there's demand
there where can we sell these things we
can't do it online like via Etsy because
they're huge and you can't we just
couldn't ship them reasonably yeah and
they're kind of weighty and this is just
shipping them ISM and big and awkward
yeah shipping would be terrible so we're
like okay it's got to be local yeah so
we found local places to sell products
like that and West Hollen came up and so
we went to West Elm or I called West
Allen we pitched the idea did we just
hear that they have a local maker
program going oh you did some googling
yeah that's not something I knew that
them beforehand they had a local maker
program yeah
so it actually sell stuff in their
stores we were advised as something that
big and that expensive wouldn't really
sell because most purchased items and
during the thing like that are kind of
impulse buys like little accessories and
this and that like not everyone goes in
to a pop-up shop or West Elm thinking
about dropping that much money on
something that they weren't planning on
doing like if they go in wanting a chair
or a table or something big yeah exactly
they don't just like see these giant
marquee letters and say I wanna spend
$400 on that this is not as much of an
impulse decision so we got that feedback
from West Mount Mazama so yeah I think
we should back up a little bit yeah
we're kind of jumping around a little
bit yeah we we got that feedback from
Wes Tom and another piece of feedback we
got cuz because what we heard is they
have this local maker program where you
can sell stuff in their stores and when
we talked to them they were like well
actually um in order to do that you
first need to sell products in store
like at these local pop-ups that we host
we're basically makers can just come in
set up shop on one of our tables and in
exchange for like promoting it on our
social media accounts week and we don't
have to you know pay us on a fee like
you do at most craft fairs you can just
go there you know it's another funny
detail I just remembered we during the
phone call with them that's when we
pitched the marquee letters yeah and
they said that's too expensive yeah you
should do something less expensive and
there are do you have anything and we're
like
yeah we have this deer yeah really good
we have a deer head we probably just
like looked around the room and then
they're like do you have a social media
account that you can use to promote
things and that's when we made evident
Caitlyn Instagram account our very first
social media account as evident Caitlyn
that's what started it all we never
intended to sell ya crazy origin story
that's like yeah I didn't think about it
that way yeah I didn't think about it
yeah cuz we never had an account like an
Instagram account for the blog because
we like weren't actually trying to grow
it or do anything with it
it's crazy that's crazy meeting like in
a few days we set up the meeting and
then we started the social media account
and then we like launched it and like
posted a few photos try to get people to
like it and we product was like 90%
family and friends we started making
products cuz we had to have a few
examples of things to bring to them yeah
do we even more than just the deer head
we might have just brought well he's
gone and overconfident with one deer
head and said we can sell stuff yeah we
did change it up a little bit we put
like a wood backing on it cuz we thought
if we're selling this we didn't know if
like fully 3d printed product if that if
people would like that kind of an
unfamiliar material you know we do paint
it metallic so it looks kind of cool
yeah but we added like a wood backing to
it and like a saachi's hanger it was a
very like finished looking piece and we
went and had our meeting and they're
like oh yeah those look pretty cool do
you want to come in like a week
yeah like you should probably have three
or four different types of products the
different price points maybe like one
that's under 15 one that's like this
price ones that's the surprise so
talking with them and getting that
information on what sells was really
quite valuable yeah I mean it was like
what sells in what environment you know
I mean it's varies a lot yeah it varies
a lot but but um the environment we
would be in would be you know setting up
a little table and people coming in to
browse and shop spontaneously buying
something yeah hopefully
so we kind of scrambled scrambled things
happen yeah well and and pop up the
reason it was so rushed just because
they were doing this like more special
event it wasn't Valentine's Day we did
we did do a Valentine's Day one it was
like a fall festival ah okay and so they
were having a whole bunch of vendors
there having food there and like free
hot chocolate and all these like fall
decorations and it was like a whole
thing so we got to meet her like so the
downside is there's a lot of pressure to
get it done on that day because it was
like oh it's gonna be a big one um but
it was cool because we got to meet a lot
of other local makers in Houston well
fun and that kind of helped kick off our
Instagram and stuff even more because I
chatted with amble and you know got me
talking about strategies yeah yeah yes
okay so think back to when we had like
50 followers and I know we didn't know
what we were doing we had no idea we're
totally like just totally winging it
what were some of the UM like challenges
you to you like what were some of the
your like memories of challenges during
the like pop-up shop days because we did
pop-up shops for a while at West um I
think that lets us before we go get on
into the pop-ups and selling the stuff I
think let's talk about like like some of
the before things more like like what
kind of like how we financed it and
stuff like that you know so I think that
in the beginning I was looking at ways
to make a whole bunch of different
things for not that expensive and I
wanted it to be scalable at the same
time so my first thought was 3d printing
one because that's what I had experience
with and I felt like it was pretty
flexible and a lot of the work could be
done without my direct supervision it
was good because I mean you were you
could just quit your job but I'm pretty
sure soon after that you would pick up
freelancing yeah and so you're already
freelancing and I was working full time
at the time and you were still looking
into other like avenues yeah we talked
about the some in the 7 tips for small
scale manufacturing I think but also I
wanted to
do something that was scalable so if we
got in an order all of a sudden for 200
or something I could buy like five 3d
printers and have them all running all
day long whereas like if we were doing
you know custom and grain cutting boards
or something that's not if you get order
for 200 all the sudden you're like oh
crap people outsource some of the work
or something but it's like the logistics
of that gets a lot it's pretty
challenging yeah it's a lot more
challenging than just buying more
printers yeah so in the beginning I
bought the printer for like prototyping
my own products helping other people you
know you know selling the 3d print
services and making these things for
West Elm and it paid for itself pretty
quickly yeah it really did you're just
surprising yeah because I had
reservations oh my god I did not want to
get a 3d printer expensive I did not
know what we were using it for
oh they're big that's gonna be it's
gonna be big it's gonna be important
it's gonna make a difference something I
don't know how I convinced you I don't
know how either he's not a cheap thing
we didn't really know I mean I trusted
that you would figure something out but
also I mean like you know financially
speaking I didn't just quit when like we
were in a tough situation we had both
been working for a long time we're both
pretty frugal living and yeah Texas and
put both of us working a job with no
kids we were we had some savings yeah I
mean you won't have quit if we didn't
have like a healthy enough cushion to
allow you to do that so yeah we had
enough cushion to buy a 3d printer -
yeah but yeah I was like we'll just put
it in the closet shut the door no one
sees it now that we've covered that I
think going back to your question of
what were the biggest challenges when we
were starting out the number one biggest
challenge for me was knowing what would
sell mmm and I think that's the biggest
problem for anyone I mean almost any
challenge can be overcome when it you
know what the challenge is
it's like manufacturing or production or
whatever you know it's like I think that
when you have a concrete problem you can
solve it I mean
being overconfident but most problems
you can solve in some way if you know
what the problem is but I think the
unknown problems are the biggest because
you can't know what people want and
people don't know what they want you
know it's like if someone told me like
what do you want to buy right now I'm
sure there's tons of things I want to
buy if I saw it and I knew it
but I don't know it and I don't I don't
exist yet you know and that like an
example of us not knowing is I think
probably what I would say is our most
successful product is the the little
Texas ornaments which I didn't expect we
just kind of did those only so that we
could have a cheap a really cheap item
yeah but it they were like it's not
really too much work that went into him
they're pretty easy we're like well
we'll just like throw those in but the
main products will be these like more
impressive things yeah and the ornaments
have been like they were the most
successful I think pretty consistently
yeah those are the main things that sold
out yet again and again yeah exactly
so and I think that was interesting that
was interesting yeah and with the 3d
printing you know not to harp on small
scale manufacturing again but it was
really nice to be able to test out ideas
with without the need for like tooling
and new machine is that all sorts of
things and you know if we did want to
scale this we could have gone to molds
and other even higher like higher
production efficiency methods and stuff
like that but I think I'm getting ahead
of myself I think that one question that
we get a lot is how much were we making
when we were selling all of that much
were we making we were making more than
we were spending definitely and I think
that when when I look at the like
dollars per hour we were making an okay
amount between like 10 and 20 dollars an
hour yeah I like our work an hour yeah
and that's pretty good you know the main
thing that that's tough is the only way
to scale that is by either putting more
man-hours in you know like hiring help
or something like that or
proving the efficiency of the
manufacturing which also takes time and
money and all of that jazz and then also
you need to be able to move that much
product yeah yeah you can become a lot
more efficient if you know that you're
gonna sell 200 of something a month but
it's hard when you're doing things like
like when we were doing the pop-up shops
we would literally just guess what we
thought we would sell I don't really
guess we go to the pop-up we'd be there
for like six hours and some pop ups were
great and some were not great oh man
somewhere when it's bad it's so painful
cuz you like put all this work in and
making all these products and getting
everything ready and making your table
look beautiful and then you're just like
but I think another thing is when you're
making products you feel good about your
time because you are making value when
you're at a pop-up store and not selling
the stuff you just feel like you're
completely wasting your time it's just
like you feel those like hours just eat
into you yeah but I think that if we had
have kept on going down that path we
would have figured out thing that's like
ramping up the social media and selling
online and you know figuring out what
sells in figuring out it doesn't sell
and we could have gotten much more
efficient I'm selling them larger
volumes that's true well we and we did
start selling and larger volumes the way
that the program at West Elm worked is
you know you do pop-up shops for a while
and if they see that your stuff is
moving well with their clientele and
you're enthusiastic and you're you know
good about sharing stuff on social media
with them and and all those things then
they can invite you to apply for the
like official local maker program where
and I don't know if it's like this for
everyone but for us we could first apply
to do it in the state of Texas so we
basically got like talked with you know
people at West Elm and got our stuff in
a catalog for the state of Texas so any
stores in Texas had the option to order
our products and we got a big order is
multi-thousand dollar orders yeah
well it was just a lot of work and we
could have you know if that have kept on
growing we would have scaled it up and
made more efficient products and yeah
all tough because like you know we we
did it in total for maybe like a year I
think well but also like during this
time we decided to start the YouTube
channel yeah and then then those two
things were competing for our time it's
like we can either ramp up in either
direction yeah I had the opportunity we
could have like double down with
products or double down with YouTube
yeah yeah and we chose you to but I
think that's not good and bad parts yeah
I wanted to talk a little bit more about
like the good and bad of doing pop-up
shops the good and bad of doing
wholesale cuz I think I mean ultimately
like Evan just said in the end we chose
to double down on YouTube but I think
products would be a better fit for a lot
of people you know it just depends on
like what you feel comfortable with and
all of that yeah exactly so I think like
the things that we learned and we have
touched on this and a couple of
different YouTube videos yeah but I
think the things we learn doing pop-up
shops and doing am selling them
individually ourselves and I think that
what do you mean like online online yeah
so I think that that um pop-up shops and
in-person events are very valuable to do
but they shouldn't be your primary
source of life yeah income and stuff
like that I think that they're good to
do because you get an impression of what
people like and kind of why when you're
just selling online on like a store
there's no feedback other than like did
they buy it or did they bother yeah and
you don't know why they didn't buy it
like like yeah one thing we found out
that from our pop-up shops is that like
someone would pick something up a lot
but they would never buy it which made
me think okay they like this it's just
too expensive yeah exactly yeah or they
pick it up at they'd ask how much it is
and then they'd be like I think that
in-person events are really important to
figure out what you want to do and then
you ramp up either with finding a whole
seller to sell it through or selling it
yourself online online yeah yeah and
setting up your online store is quite a
lot of work but once you get it set up
right and you have your boxes you have
your packaging you have your labels all
done and all of those logistics are
streamlined I think it's pretty nice but
if you don't have a streamlined it's
just like some shipping and packing and
all of that is
really painful yeah especially when
you're doing like one or two sales a day
you need to like take a break from your
day re pull out all that supplies and
you don't have a station for it you
don't have stuff set up for it I think
that once you get a certain volume
shipping isn't bad but well I mean I
would say it's probably more efficient
more efficient and it's not as painful
for some reason because I think like
when you have to take a break from your
day pull out all the packing stuff pack
it take it to the take it to like UPS
then that's like a long chunk of time
for one product for one product but if
you do them like you know 50 a week and
you ship them out once a week then like
you you set aside the time you print
everything at once you put them all in
the boxes and take them all to the
shipping place at once I think that's
where efficiency comes in also I think
if you're doing that volume you're not
at the point where you're like I'm
working on stuff and I have to take a
break yeah yeah so I and and for
wholesale at bigger outlets and stuff
like that I think that has a big draw
because of the consistency of the work
you know you you know an order bigger
numbers all of that you have to make
sure you have enough profit margin in
your say your sale price so you need to
make things really cheaply and that you
have to be sell you have to be able to
sell them for more to get a good profit
because you know you're sharing your
profits with someone else yeah and
you're sharing like 50 percent like it's
not an insignificant amount and I do
think especially when you're smaller I
think I understand the value of that
because when we were trying to sell our
own products and we didn't have a
platform that was painful yeah I mean
it's better to sell some you know it's
better to sell products and have some
profit eaten up than to not be selling
any of your products that you've made
you know clean you're not making
anything but yeah we didn't we didn't
really have enough of a cushion to make
it to like incentivize us to keep doing
the wholesale like enough of a profit
cushion yeah like like when we were
doing pop-ups we you know we were making
a decent amount but our me
per product yeah you know we sold we
sold some but we sold a lot more at
doing wholesale but it was just so much
per product for so much work yeah and I
think also another thing is especially
with like the deer head specifically
this isn't something we thought about
when we designed it and it wasn't a huge
deal when we were doing local pop-up
shops but it's a single item that has to
go into a twelve by twelve inch box yeah
and that's really expensive to ship and
at least with the wholesale program with
West um we are responsible for the cost
of all of our shipping yeah and so
that's another thing that eats into your
profit margins you don't think about
yeah like 12 dollars just a ship I'm so
crazy how complex and expensive shipping
is when like cuz everyone's used to it
was on now no you just go online and
it's free and it just shows up real
quick yeah that's so unrealistic yeah
and I didn't realize how unrealistic it
was until we tried to do it ourselves
and now I just feel bad for any company
that has to compete with Amazon and
let's all just like a beast when it
comes to shipping like I'm used to you
know I I even know how hard it is to
ship and the logistics and the stocking
issues and stuff like that to some
degree and it's just like ah anyway
that's that's another thing yeah
sometimes what questions now people who
are seeing watched like our old how to
sell handmade products video and stuff
like that and they're like well wouldn't
your Etsy and all you have t-shirts now
we're like yeah ok so let's talk about
the good parts for a little bit because
we've been kind of hovering on the bad
parts and why we moved on okay so the
good parts is I love designing products
and making them could often be really
fun and therapeutic yeah it was like a
cool opportunity to just put on your
headphones and kind of chill yeah and do
something like just the right amount of
mindless you know when you're making
multiple things yeah and it was kind of
nice kind of nice
and it was nice making physical things
we like making physical things another
good part about it was like oh I thought
it was a cool way this is an unexpected
benefit but like meeting the other
makers in our area yeah you know like
and we we haven't like kept in touch
that well now that we're so such an
YouTube thing for a while you know like
we would go out to dinner with some
people we made stuff like that like we
would you know keep in touch on
Instagram and it's like it was a it's a
cool community and we still like follow
them on Instagram and stuff but um I
thought that was a cool unexpected
aspect and I don't think you would get
that as much if you weren't doing local
things yeah which it would be that's
another benefit of doing local things
and I also think even if you switched to
doing mainly online or wholesale I still
think there's certain times of year like
around the holidays where it's
beneficial to do local things and like
I'll get your money out of your time
another good thing is you know there's
there's kind of a precedent and there's
kind of a path I can known path for
stuff like this like selling products
you know it's kind of like there's books
written about it there's people with
experience there's all sorts of known
things relative to YouTube which is like
so unknown and a little bit more chaotic
and like it's Wild West out here and
like yeah there's less like widely
applicable tips in YouTube yeah aside
from really generic things like we could
condone which is completely undefinable
yeah but there's like a lot more I think
because you know people have been doing
it for a longer than there are more
solid tips I mean like people have been
making and selling stuff for like
forever forever yeah pretty much
yeah there's more like places now that
you can do it like with the internet
yeah yeah so I think those are some of
the good things the main bad part is
sometimes it got repetitive yeah
sometimes I got rid of I think if it was
our primary thing I I don't know if the
a petition would have bothered me but I
think because it well I think the main
diet thing for me is it felt started to
feel like it was taking away time from
YouTube yeah that's why I like the
repetitive would get to me cuz we'd be
like well I came up with this idea of
something gonna do for a video and since
new thing it's really cool first we got
to make 30 more geometric Texas's yeah
you know I think that with my experience
of making now I think it would be more
fun yes I think we could do more
interesting things I think silicone
molds and resin and concrete and like
CNC and all this stuff like we could be
like like production madhouses like
would have liked all three three all
four 3d printers running at the same
time making things and we can have the
CNC going mold make well you would have
molds like with resin and concrete in
them and like I would literally be doing
only resin I don't want to do wood I
don't you 3d print I would just do resin
like be like a dozen masters yeah I'd be
like the resin lady like I just want to
do like geodes mainly just gonna be like
making resin would have like a known
thing a solid thing and honestly didn't
random crazy things in the background
like like moonshot projects that like
might be cool or might become yeah but I
think the reason I like resin appeals to
me is cuz even though it's repetitive
it's different every time yeah that's
totally true yeah we could come up with
like five main products at a couple
different price points yeah and you
could just be like doing that boom boom
boom that would be really fun actually
yeah like I think if that if we were
gonna pick up products again that's what
kind of thing I did yeah and I think
with with everything at the very
beginning sometimes things can be a
little bit painful but they're I think
that they're totally worth it they're
totally worth figuring out and doing
well I think it also like it helped us
learn kind of how to use social media as
a business you know because we started
doing that with the product business
yeah you know so it's like even if you
think you know if you're maybe kind of
interested in doing content creation and
maybe kind of interested in products I
think there are skills that
overlap you know so you can just start
with whichever one is more in your reach
right now which for us I mean at the
time we started content creation wasn't
really on our radar but I know there's
some people that are interested in both
so you know skills you can learn they
can overlap very nicely but I think that
when we were started doing both YouTube
just took over for us we loved making
videos we love exploring and continually
pushing everything I think it's easier
to overlap them if you're doing custom
products oh yeah you know what I mean
because then you can make a video about
your products that's different every
time yeah you know if you're making the
same time five products in huge batches
it's a lot harder to make videos about
that I mean we've done it like we made
like the video that was about making a
tea coasters in one weekend or whatever
you know and so you can do that but I
feel like you can only do that so many
times where if you know you're Jimmy and
you're making like custom signs and
stuff like that and it's different sets
of skills every time and I was like I
thought I couldn't do a video on this
one because I'll be fine but you know
but you know he's making a table thing
he's making a sign then he's making a
knife so I feel like that's an easier
way to overlap content creation and
product making if it's custom yeah and
or and or if you're constantly
experimenting with new things even if
it's like let's say that you're doing
resin but you're doing different types
of resin things different morals
different like like like you used to
resin and you do resin and alcohol inks
and resin and pigment then resin then
you know yeah you can oh oh yeah yeah so
now that I'm talking about I'm getting
more excited about it again but I'm
still a hundred percent like committed
to this path yeah but who knows maybe in
the future sometime it's like we want to
do some kind of side thing yeah yeah we
don't have time right now
I think looking back on things if
YouTube hadn't have taken off and
grabbed hold of us in such an exciting
way I think that we might have gone down
in the path of making products I think
so I think we would have pushed farther
into it and like
okay go for it I think we would have
pushed farther into it and tried
different types of making and pushed
farther I mean we did we were in the
process of pushing a little bit farther
like we started with the 3d printing
stuff and then we had introduced seeing
some CNC products to our film library
and I think we just continued to
introduce the concrete that was actually
pretty early so we had 3d printing
concrete and we were doing the CMC we
haven't even started down the resin yeah
so I think we would have continued to
like experiment with new products yeah
um I do think when you're doing
wholesale it's harder to experiment
because you can't just like put it up on
your shop you have to go through an
approval process yeah it's a big thing
it's like a huge thing to change a price
or to add a product yeah but I think
that that would have been a fun path to
go down on yeah I think the other aspect
now that I'm remembering through our
thought process is the fact that we kind
of wanted to keep the business just the
two of us yeah for the most part I mean
who knows one day we might hire on more
help and we've gone back and forth on
editing and yeah we've got some
part-time awesome stuff but I think that
right now we're so we're so rapidly
shifting and dynamic and our goals and
our videos and our projects and all that
we highly value our flexibility right
now and I think that the more people you
bring on the more responsibility you
take on the less flexible you can be to
some degree yeah and I do think you know
with content creation you can kind of if
things are working you can just keep
doing them and your business grows and
scales with your audience and reach
exactly where as what products it it
grows when you can make more yeah you
know I think someone was inevitable yeah
if the two of us can make like 10
products per day or per week or whatever
that like number it is at whatever scale
product it is you know we can only get
so efficient yeah we can't like to
continue to increase the price of a
table we make yeah like as we get but
like you know I thought
that much better yeah yeah like the only
thing is the only way you can cut cost
is inefficiency and time yeah exactly
and if you're if you're charging more
for a table it's got to be a nicer table
meaning it probably takes more time yeah
yeah so it's like yeah that was another
looking at the selling conundrum where
like I think that because we just really
liked working from home mm-hmm and we
like being flexible yeah just being able
to be in our PJs yeah like going back to
the root of why we started this I think
we've touched on this a few times but we
just were going after a particular life
we wanted we wanted to spend time
together we wanted to have a flexible
work-life balance even though right now
it's all work it's like work work
balance but we wanted all of those
things and I think that bringing more
people into the equation would have
taken away some of that and we might
have needed to go to another location
and then it might have just turned into
a work-life balance that wasn't what we
were aiming for yeah yeah thanks so I
think that's why we chose to do YouTube
among other reasons yeah
why we've backed off of products yeah my
products I think are a really cool
solution for a lot of different people
yeah
so we move on to our game
all right so two truths and a lie
how well do you know me how well do you
know me pretty well I mean coming up
with these ideas it's actually hard it
was really hard cuz like you know so
much about me yeah I did I had to like
think of things that happened before we
knew each other which was a really long
time ago yeah okay so I'm I'm sure
everyone knows what two truths and a lie
is but just in case you don't it's
basically each of us will take turns
saying three statements about ourselves
two of them are true one is a lie and
the other person has to guess the lie
such as I took piano lessons I took the
car guitar lessons
I took swimming lessons which is the lie
okay walk walk them say with me so you
teach one okay well I know that you were
on the swim team yes I'm assuming you
took swimming lessons at some point as a
child
most children that I knew took swimming
lessons so I'm gonna say that one's true
but the two instruments are throwing me
off because I do not know you as the
person that has musical talent I'm gonna
say that you took piano and that the
guitar is a lie yeah you're right really
how did you know I don't know I don't
know one or two piano lessons
really and I'm not like because I think
like the way he told me to like like the
way he was instructing me I'm like I
don't like that that's just everything I
didn't like the instructor I guess it's
like you know he was like oh I don't
know I guess when you start learning the
piano you have to start with like the
notes and memorizing things and stuff
like that and just wasn't appealing if
he was a bad my brother took guitar
lessons oh really
did he like it yeah he took them for
quite a while
really yeah oh wow well he took them for
a period of time he still has a guitar
maybe lately yeah so I think that he's
like trying to pick up the ukulele again
yeah
but uh in swimming lessons I thought I'd
throw that in there cuz I've been
swimming for my entire life but like I
didn't know because my mom was also a
swim instructor so I didn't know if like
you thought that like she might have
taught me and then I didn't actually
ever take some lessons and stuff trick
you too much was maybe there was like a
hint of maybe that's a lie because it
was so obviously yes right right yeah I
tried to be strategic about this okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna I've seen lava in
real life I've gone paragliding I've
been swimming with dolphins
you've been paragliding is lie well
Daniels fast like Bob I know you've been
to Hawaii
yeah not everyone sees it in real life
it's like yes quite a track not you know
fighters no I knew paragliding I thought
that would have come up you know it's
because I went skydiving you probably
would've brought up paragliding no but
it wasn't for you know it was on a
Disney cruise Islands seem believable
for some reason why wouldn't I have told
you that I swam with dolphins before
that's really cool you know I like to
like do things with animals yeah yeah
okay that was a pretty good one but I
just knew yeah okay I can hold my breath
for two minutes I've never been stung by
a bee and I'm allergic to scorpions
I think the lie is two minutes no I've
done it for two minutes
yeah two minutes till though I've done
it for two minutes
you have done it before that says you
can I have held my breath for two
minutes okay you get one more guys so
the other two are that you've never been
stung by a bee yes and that you are
allergic to scorpion yes sorry they're
like one of them being a like negative
like a never and the other one being an
okay I think I think that you are
allergic to scorpions and you have been
stung by a bee nope I've never been sung
by V what isn't
allergic to scorpion I know I put that
in there too Zelda Yahoo yeah you've
never insane baby never been somebody
that I guess that's why I'm not as
afraid of them as you are happy but Sun
baby well nervin some maybe but I've
been sung by Yellowjackets and wasps
what's the yellow jack gonna be Oh
yellowjacket oh yeah these are good and
Yellow Jackets suck Oh Yellow Jackets
are like evil
I know Hornets can sting you multiple
times without dying and bees this sting
you don't die
yeah Yellow Jackets Yellow Jackets are
just like the meanest bugs in the world
our Yellow Jackets bees no they're not
bees they're I guess closer no wasps oh
yeah yeah evil beasts but they don't
look like bees they're not like not
fuzzy yeah no no not as eaten fuzzy
they're mean we had a nest at my house
once and I got stung by one and I was a
little kid and I was very upset I didn't
understand why they would do that still
traumatized as I can see so traumatized
it's happened like multiple time okay I
used to collect beanie babies I used to
collect coins I used to collect pogs
you'd never collected coins I've never
mentioned pogs to you before hello but
like I just know you you you would
concoct I had a few coins but I didn't
collect them like Pokemon you excited
Pokemon cards you know totally it was
like a different era pogs were before
pokemon cards by a decent amount you
have good ones but I just know you like
your personality yeah III hmm fine
that's like doing that to anyone else
but they'd have a hard time good
questions
nitrogen fogs that's a good Slammers
man but vlogs are great pugs are great
yeah I had some I never like went into
collecting them but I like you're
awesome by the way I think you're really
cool thank you okay I used to play
soccer I used to play baseball and I
used to play hockey I'm going to guess
the last hockey you're right mainly
because like hockey is more popular up
north and you didn't live anywhere up I
didn't I didn't yeah I never met anyone
who like played hockey on a hockey like
chosen like another sport that I didn't
play but I played like a lot of sports I
played tennis I played baseball I play
basketball I played soccer when other
sports are football oh yeah I didn't
like basketball the most I ran like once
and it wasn't great some of these
questions are giving me ideas for like
next time we play this yeah okay yeah
okay I once won a soccer tournament
I once won the science fair I once won a
poetry competition
oh it's science fair a poetry
competition on the guest poetry is the
lie is the lie you are wrong Oh was it
science fair you are wrong I never won a
soccer tournament I've been to
tournaments we just never won the
tournament oh man you've you've won
matches everyone matches that was a good
one yeah so but I did win I won the like
my school science fair and the Houston
science fair and I went to state but I
didn't won state
yeah you told me that you won the
science fair I remember that story with
the oven yeah yeah we made like like
custom pizza racks
all right oven yeah yeah I don't know
how
don't it was like the least scientific
but we had a really we didn't really get
a competent I really good powerpoints
and yeah played we played the song wrap
them up that's pretty awesome and then I
want to poetry contest do you wanna hear
the poem yes please
does that mean you're like for know I
was in like second grade when I won my
school-wide poetry contest I had to read
it in front of the whole school okay
yeah I have a cat my cat is fat he
chewed up my hat because I shout its cat
he's mean and he's fat a big fat nasty
old cat I watched that video you showed
it to me it sounds like I didn't like my
cat at the time I actually loved my cat
at the time I have never seen The Sound
of Music
I've never seen The Godfather I've never
seen et you've never seen The Godfather
I haven't seen The Godfather
cuz I was like okay you have to have
seen et cuz that's such a good movie
okay and Sound of Music I feel like
you've referred to it or something I've
never seen this sense the sound of music
oh wait I got it except sorry because
I've never seen wait so which movie have
you not seen okay so I've never seen The
Sound of Music
I've never seen the Godfather I've never
seen et what is it a lie oh wait so I
said you've never seen The Godfather and
you said that's correct so that's the
lie right that's what I've never seen
The Godfather
I've never okay so I can eliminate that
one so it's me there so these are ET or
Sound of Music
okay Sound of Music yeah music was like
that's the one that it's you seem least
likely to have seen oh yeah and so I was
like maybe throwing that in there yeah
super long so like I
seen The Sound of Music I have seen the
Godfather I have seen et I don't know
you should have just like not gone
excited okay here I am I have a similar
okay I've never seen The Sound of Music
what what I've never seen Back to the
Future I've never seen Pulp Fiction
you've never seen Sound of Music is that
which one what's the truth okay truth
okay so read it again you've never seen
this out of music I need to guess the
true one which is the true one which one
this game it's just confusing with the
negative okay okay you seen one of these
yeah yeah I've seen yeah so I've never
seen Back to the Future is that true or
false I've never seen The Sound of Music
is that true or false I've never seen
Pulp Fiction is that true or false Pulp
Fiction is the one you have seen that's
false
yeah yes I almost chose for fiction
that's the weird thing I almost chose
Sound of Music and Pulp Fiction but I
know you know that I haven't seen pull
fiction because we've talked about
perfect we have seen it and I haven't
and have this discussion of like movies
you need to see before you die or
something I don't know these lists take
two really bad options the never ones
are confusing confusing yeah okay so
yeah I once ate three cheese pizzas by
myself how big I want eight six items
from Taco Bell I participated in the
formal eating contest
which is the lie the lie is the formal
eating contest I shouldn't have said
formal eating contest cuz like I've
participated in an eating contest
everyone's done that because everyone's
like done that with our friends our
family are having right
I think what was your eating contest
probably the three pizzas
bear-like CC's Oh swimming like six days
a week for three hours I hate like well
you know like the Michael Phelps thing
not that much but like well I knew like
Taco Bell I knew that's doable cuz like
you could probably if you were super
hungry eat six Taco Bell items yeah that
was a fun that if I'm sorry my parents
were like at a charity auction for some
reason I don't know it sounds so weird
like they're at a charity auction and
one of the things was like an
all-you-can-eat Taco Bell party for like
like a sports team I mean the whole swim
team was there and all of us like like
we closed down to talk about and it was
like an all-you-can-eat Taco Bell party
the best type of party I think we like
my parents got a huge value for that cuz
like people were on it because I was
talked about no one else had a reason to
do it so they got it for pretty cheap I
think and like we totally got a good
value for it that's why and I'm guessing
you went to cc's with your swim team too
because that's like what all we did that
with our how many pizzas can we but see
after a practice - sounds like we have
been swimming for and working out for so
long
combined I shouldn't have been formal
eating contest yeah the word formal do
it off okay if I have no I still would
have guessed eating contest just cause
like the Taco Bell I was like that's
totally doable you would totally eat six
items yeah the three pizzas I was like
that sounds so exaggerated it has to be
true cause a lot of pizza a lot of pizza
and I just knew that you used to eat a
lot okay I have one I've seen Snoop Dogg
in concert I've seen the offspring in
concert true true I've seen Linkin Park
in concert false
know what the false one is offspring
I never seen offspring in concert I
thought you wouldn't I did and I would
have loved to see them huh I thought
we'd talk about like a wish we had I've
seen like a Linkin Park I've seen Lea
convert twice twice okay but it was in
high school and I saw Snoop Dogg because
he opened for a Linkin Park which is a
really weird combo if you think about it
that's weird it's weird I visited over
50 countries well this is hard because I
know you've visited a buttload of
countries so I don't know the exact
number you could have visited 49
Antarctica one day I don't know all 50
states
Antarctica's the lie ah dang it cuz I
you know you don't like cold
travel-related thing and I had the 50
countries and 50 states
I never took us geography guys I didn't
learn the song like Alabama I mean your
defense I don't know I would have to
really think about it you know the song
no I don't know the song now oh there
was an anime nyet song that listed the
capitals just the 50 states I thought we
were talked about states once and you
started like trying to sing a song
there's a song Animaniacs on me but it
or maybe it was the 50 states I don't
know there's an immediate I've lived
overseas for like eight seven or eight
years my life and I miss out on some
like pop culture things cartoons we got
a good amount of cartoons there all the
old cartoons
I got Animaniacs okay it was old yeah we
got like Tom and Jerry we got the Space
Ghost
Mighty Mouse yeah
mmm-hmm Ivan ironically worn a vest
I've on eclis worn a fake nose ring and
ivan i rana Klee worn chains on my pants
nose ring I know you you know I have a
real stylish breast and Cheney pants oh
yeah yeah oh I could a hundred percent
connected Shane Vance cuz you look
through the Hot Topic face did you get
the vest
oh no no photos of like your different
styles throughout your like my Hot Topic
day as a nose ring would have been like
a logical thing no but let's no you you
wouldn't Bend the nose ring a fake nose
ring but you wore it like no pretty good
valiant attempt okay I graduated in the
top 5% of my class in high school for my
prom I didn't go out for a meal i
home-cooked it in high school I
volunteered more than 100 hours oh man
okay the things with numbers are hard
because it's like if your number was a
little bit off like then I could guess
it and the sentiment would be correct
but the number is like one percent off
or one thing off I I think the top 5% of
your class are you trying to father I am
dumb no you just weren't the most
studious I know I didn't do my homework
until the night before what would make
you think that years of seeing it but I
I you cooking for prom I could see that
uh-huh and that I actually didn't know
too much about the volunteer hours I was
like I think I was I'm like a leadership
role in my National Honor Society Oh
and that you needed that like do not add
hours of volunteering yeah how about
that for Humanity oh nice yeah yeah cool
cool you making stuff I've been on the
local news about a week-long snow day
I've been on the local news about a
summer heat wave I've been on the local
news about Harry Potter I know the Harry
Potter one cuz I saw that okay snow day
or summer heat wave which one have I
been on the news about you've been on
the news for a heat wave not this cold
one yeah cuz I know you've lived there
haven't been that many snow things yeah
but you know about the like North
Carolina week of like snow days the epic
week of snow I want to find that clip of
that okay we're at the pool mm-hmm
and there's like the news crew cuz I'm
the news crew what are you you ask me
how I deal with the summer heat the
crazy summer heat how do you deal with
the crazy summer heat okay keep in mind
I'm like I'm like seven yeah well I go
swimming in the pool I stay in the shade
and drink Sunny D oh I happen to be
holding a thing of Sunny D we might I
want to find that and put it on
Instagram oh my god I have the Harry
Potter clip yeah that was I've never
seen lost in translation I've never seen
American Psycho I've never seen Silence
of the Lambs I know that the Silence of
the Lambs one is true cuz we've talked
about that and I want you to watch it I
think you have seen American Psycho so I
think that's the lie
really I've never seen American Psycho
and I have seen lost in translation
really yeah
the interesting thing about lost in
translation I've never seen lost in
translation but I've seen American
Psycho the first time I watch lost in
translation wait lost I was bored I was
really bored throughout the whole movie
the second time I watched it I was like
this is a good movie really and that's
the first time that's happened to me
yeah I think I was like back when when
we like watch movies with friends like
socially and stuff and like like I watch
it with friends twice and this like yeah
I wasn't picking the movie yeah whatever
whatever people pick you know and so
they I kind of got forced to watch it
twice and I not forced the him like sit
down you watch this right now but I
don't know maybe I was in a different
point in life maybe I went in with lower
expectations and it was better or maybe
you like saw shadowing or elements that
like tied into things that ya weren't
revealed until later in the yeah but the
first time it was just so boring and I
didn't care or something was it pretty
far apart that you saw them decently far
apart maybe like about a year because
sometimes like movie taste might change
yeah and that's kind of like artsy or
quirky movies it is you know we're like
I think that wraps up our game segment
even more I want to do so we have to do
this again yeah
we played like I definitely do again cuz
like they're fun to come up with
questions they're fun to share things
with each other yeah there's a good way
to share stories with you guys yeah how
many questions people got right versus
wrong Oh play along
yeah so we want to do two truths and a
lie and I also want to play never have
ever with you oh that would be fine we
need to come up with a soundtrack for
that too I just did
of the week is multi camera editing but
your glasses like the motion of like oh
just felt like I should also inhale air
in a weird way in the same direction I
don't know what I was thinking multicam
editing the neat thing about that is
multiple cameras running at the same
time to you so stress you out
used to stress me out so much because it
complicates the editing process a ton
it's so much more footage to go through
it like bogs down your computer more you
have to keep everything aligned any time
you want to cut your clip and make a
shift I would have to like I would line
up you know let's say four different
cameras cameras worth of Clips and if I
wanted to make a shift I'd have to cut
four different cameras worth of footage
and then shift it over but you know
we've had this suggested to us before
and I just never really took the time to
learn how to do it and then once I did
it was pretty easy like put a link to
the tutorial I used
you can basically set it up where it
Auto syncs different cameras and then
you can toggle on and off viewing just
the camera you've selected versus
viewing all four or however many of them
and you can select which one you want to
show for each clip yeah it's so neat and
it's especially handy if you're like
like the resin projects for example yeah
because we have a lot of multi camera
stuff going on because you know with
resin you pour it once it's not
something where it's not like you're
gonna be making twenty cuts on the table
saw and you have multiple chances to get
at you've one chance so you want to get
it from a couple angles is the first
project use it on the battling of the
carts my efforts for the mario kart
battle for the battle itself again you
know we have like a far back view to get
us we had a close-up of the robots we
had top-down view and one on the robots
we had four cameras earning at the same
time yep which is a ton of footage to go
through and it's very hard to review
them when you're constantly having to
just like toggle on and off each
individual track and you can view all
four at once and the multi cam yeah it's
way easier to be like oh that's the
camera I want to go with for this scene
yeah so maybe in the description down
below we'll link we go into that video
you can see you can like see it in
action we'll link to the tutorial I use
yeah sounds good yeah awesome this is
really fun yeah okay secret behind the
scenes thing for those of you who knees
yeah stunts October and the secret is
we're recording this on the 18th because
we're about to go to work rhymes con in
a little bit gone boy and that comes out
yeah so this is being released right
after workbench gone we're recording it
the same day our last episode was
released glad you remember it because
it's not like ingrained in our habits to
do the podcast it's not on our calendar
either not on calendar yeah we just kind
of remember to record it every Friday or
Saturday issue yeah
and so yeah yeah that's the end on the
bang thanks for tuning in guys
and we'll see you next time